okay a different University yes that
would a it is Harvard Business School so
Harvard is obviously a fantastic
Business School it's always done
strongly in our ranking so this is the
first time that it has been number one
since we started ranking business
schools in 1988 Wow
so what happened the story with Harvard
is students get great salaries as soon
as they graduate they six to eight years
out they still have really strong
careers and employers recruiters who
hire MBAs love Harvard so those are
supportive of the things we ranked
schools on and they did really strongly
on those measures right because last
year was Duke rats right so what
happened there with Duke Duke fell a
little and part of the reason for some
of the reshuffling is that we did refine
our methodology this year so it's not
all completely apples to apples but Duke
also performs really strongly in
employer ratings people who hire MBAs
also left to hire from Duke right I mean
these are all you know the top of the
top when it comes to business schools
that's right when you mentioned you
change the methodologies methodology so
what was the biggest change there we
refined our methodology so that we're
focusing on what we think people who go
to business will really care about
getting a great job getting a great
career that means not just making a lot
of money but ending up in on a career
path that they feel good about so we
asked about all kinds of things that
have to do with careers job placement
salary levels when they graduate and
also what alumni think six to eight
years out of school this is the first
year that we've actually surveyed alumni
so right we talked to 12,000 beautiful
graduates yeah if you look at the screen
there I mean Stanford so Stanford ranked
number one in salary and alumni survey
data that's like what what was behind
that people who end up you know people
who graduate from Stanford end up making
a lot of money right when they graduate
that's one of the salary data points
that we look at and alumni are really
happy with the way that the school helps
them get to where they are in their
careers so not only are they in careers
that they make a lot of money in but
they feel like Stanford helped them get
there and they also report being really
satisfied in their careers it also
matters whether you're in a job you like
right right well and I hear a lot
anecdotally about how the Stanford
Network is really really tight maybe so
Harvey's is but Stanford particularly in
Silicon Valley right and there's swirl
there are so many resources available
through the school and in the valley in
general to help people get into tech and
to startups and really make a lot of
connections there in the school and its
students really really capitalized on
that so let's talk about salaries then
what did you find in when you were doing
this in this ranking what did you find
in terms of salary earnings as the years
progressed as well one of the really
interesting data points that we focused
on that we found was that there is a pay
gap between male and female MBAs it
starts out pretty small so when they
graduate men are making they're both
making somewhere around 100 I think men
make 98 and women make 105 thousand
dollars a year but six to eight years
out that pay gap has grown to 140 women
170 men so 140 175 men yes so gender
seems to affect everybody not you know
women in all kinds of career paths even
MBAs where you would think men and women
would be on kind of an equal playing
field and what I thought was really
interesting about this is that what's
driving that gender pay gap is bonuses
it's not the base salary that's changed
differing that much it's how much
they're getting paid when it comes to
discretionary income so it suggests that
you know it's not just it you know that
you can get a good base salary but it
still matters what employers think when
they're about your Peschel army right
here and some of that's discretionary so
it's sort of interesting well what stuck
out to me was at what Columbia had the
worst gender pay gap right men are six
to eight years out or making almost a
hundred thousand dollars more than women
a hundred thousand you know and we can't
we can't say now this is because they
went to Columbia but it's interesting
for business schools I think to look at
these numbers and think what are we
doing not just to let in enough women
but to also make sure that they're
thriving when they graduate and despite
all this you know focus on the tech
world most of the MBAs are still going
in what finance and consulting that's
right 60% of all MBAs end up in finance
consulting and and tech so we you know
we really see that's almost half going
into consulting and finish yeah yes
absolutely so we really see them driving
the same industries you always think of
them driving